ciao ragazzi poi tornati alla nuova
puntata di cucina buttata che noi che
succede che è jasmin per favore poi
chiamata per favore
il tool moroso colui al quale le guance
si trasformano in laghi di porpora
quando si parla di te chissenefrega del
big mac
neanche
sì
per materiale scottante no un po di
tempo fa abbiamo provato a fare il
cristo at the con poi abbiamo provato a
fare i chicken mcnuggets tutte ricette
che erano solamente preludio a un unico
panino che meritava di essere fatto io
non sono d'accordo ma funzionava per
creare pathos veniamoci un attimo
l'unico vero panino che esiste il big
mac che comunque è meno buono
ragazzi siete ti incristi ott indichi
mac le detto in modo tale che uno non
potevamo dire crispi
in realtà la cosa veramente difficile da
imitare dei panini del mcdonald's sono
le salse noi però abbiamo un esercito di
hacker che è riuscito ad accedere a un
blog che si chiama fox valley food i.com
di quelli che lo sciopero in descrizione
da effettivamente un'idea di salsina da
creare quando si va a fare di gmac ora
io non mangio come qualcuno si ricorda
che saprà io quindi sarei molto critico
perfetto a parte gli scherzi
abbiamo già armato che quindi oggi se il
nostro esperto la faccenda si fa ancora
più intrigante la faccenda si fa ancora
più intrigante per fare la salsa del mic
mano tutti gli ingredienti non abbiamo
tutti gli ingredienti
ma serve di base la maionese senape
ragazzi mi sapete reso conto che questo
senape conviene la mostra
vabbè ma il senape con miele ragazzi non
si può fare
aspetta no invece sì perché serve monti
spiego in che modo la senape con miele
ci salva e voi tutti zitti ma dobbiamo
vincere subito
se ranieri con la mostrata in banca
questa volta che si chiama suite velez è
una salsa agrodolce fatta con i
cetriolini noi quindi in questo momento
abbiamo una carenza di zucchero
all'interno della falsa ma che
prenderemo dal miele stata essere così
dicendo in pochi riescono a notare
cetriolini vino bianco al centro di vino
bianco anno in polvere cipolla in
polvere backup manca questa salsa
speciale citrini con dello zucchero
volevo mettere ma usiamo il miele
fidarvi di me forse ha trovato la chiave
di volta in realtà grazie uno riesce a
credere in me master in realtà in
italiano e senape non lo star da fine io
non ci vedo
ecco cosa voglio sentire teniamo i
nostri viewers con l'attenzione alta non
stanno vedendo un programma di cucina è
un thriller
ragazzi siamo ancora a guardare e passa
sono passati venti minuti dall'inizio di
questa cosa un po lenti all'inizio di
san
abbiamo bisogno di una tazza di ragazzi
questi compratevi di lasciami link sotto
questi sommitali vitali per farle mie
dice una tazza di maionese me cojoni
dalla stanza preferita lati buona sai
qual è maionese e barbe che insieme ma
per me è buono contaminato in su peso
maionese e poi in sospeso barbe che
mangio non mischiato tu sei uno che odia
vero quando la contaminazione o mangi
divisi si siete team noi o team stupito
fate rosolare con un cucchiaio e mezzo
di mostarda ricordiamoci che dentro
questa mostarda c'è anche del miele poi
ci aggiungiamo spezzatini e citro di lei
e jaka cola cola poi qua sotto in
descrizione vi mettiamo pure se non
usate le razze come fare con i
millilitri grammi e compagnia bella
comunque un cucchiaio e mezzo su comodi
punti non dirlo le son comodo mezzo
cucchiaino di paprika un quarto di
polvere taglio min questo qui non è
ammazzato è un quarto a questa qui aglio
quelle altre cipolla dobbiamo creare
questa salsina
col pestello ma che è il nome della rosa
che stiamo facendo a questa non
l'abbiamo messa vabbè sta un po andando
così chiedo scusa sono un po confuso ma
qua sotto vi mettiamo tutte quante le
cose che dovete infilare qua dentro un
cucchiaio e mezzo quindi un quarto di
taza video spettatori demo no io non lo
mangiano i secoli gli omaggi dei secoli
ora mi faccio guidare dalla popolazione
della cucina sì sto seguendo una voce
nella mia testa che sta parlando e mi
sta facendo fare questa salsa un pochino
veloce è come se la stessi creando io la
salsa questa quindi butta con lo sguardo
deciso il trita patate ti piace come
idea credo che sia una come l'idea
pessima
buona comunque è buonissima come salvo
la mia assaggiarlo forse un po più dice
trio allora inizialmente c'è poi si
perde poi di nuovo torna bambino guarda
che ci sta perché a quelle retrone è
giusto multare è giusto in frigo a usare
un po passiamo al panico sono fiducioso
è tipico del team stupidi era il momento
di fare gli hamburger si utilizzano il
più largo per fare hamburger prendo il
macinato facendo i conti per poter
mangiare tutti noi sono un 120 g di
hamburger facciamo 100 ragazzi
no non è perfetto ragazzino perfetto
a tra poco alla fine ha messo 120 grammi
iniziamo a mettere i due hamburger da
100 grammi da 120 g no
dopo si cala a fine cottura e diventa
una scarpa
il pane lo riscalda remo al forno dal
momento che il big mac ha due strade
questi sono abbastanza piatti dovremo
usare un'antica tecnica di hokuto che
adesso vi mostrerò prendiamo un panino
quello tagliamo a metà a questo punto ne
prendiamo un altro e togliamo la parte
sotto quella subito sopra prof
tu mi hai rotto il codice
adesso anche con gli altri
abbiamo fatto con un periodo con gli
avanzi della roma è arrivato il momento
di preparare gli ultimi ingredienti che
serviranno per l'assemblaggio finale
cipolla per me un profumo di dior ci
[Musica]
della shell
[Applauso]
intanto abbiamo tirato fuori i panini
dal forno in modo da atto star lì
leggermente
ricapitoliamo qui abbiamo cipolla
insalata cetrioli la salsa il pane
a questo punto manca la carne riscaldare
mo tre fette e metteremo sciogliere il
gender sopra abbiamo scoperto che il
formaggio sta solamente nel piano
inferiore e sotto è sotto l'hamburger è
l'amante che si nasconde sotto al letto
è vero non ho mai fatto vedere gli
ingredienti e l'hamburger fare l'albero
mettiamo sopra il bar è arrivato il
momento quindi di assemblare primo
strato salsa cipolla tritata l'insalata
e così va il formaggio con sopra labour
quindi noi prendiamo il panino e lo
rigidi amo tramezzo del panino di nuovo
alza di nuovo la cipolla
poi aveva un po dice violini la carne e
si chiude il parto
wow
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine della
nostra ricetta è perfetto viva di
raggiungermi che non abbiamo fazzoletti
bravo a 321 di a sapere che cosa faccio
devo dire che lo ial parlami d'amore ma
della salsa del big mac è più decisa
vera bomba ha sapore non è di mac no
fini c che si abitua
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video noi non sono più capace nel
di volere
io in questo momento non voglio parlare
voglio solamente un applicare come
sempre pagatemi su instagram fatemi
sapere se eri proveniente a fare questa
ricetta io sono contento emilia stessa
cosa dovete vostri esperimenti se le è
piaciuto questo video iscrivetevi al
canale attivate la campanera delle
notifiche per non perdere le prossime
uscite ma soprattutto ci vediamo
domenica prossima alle 12 con un altro
episodio di cucina buttata ciao
tu hai fatto ciao quello mangiava e
basta ma basta del team non ha deciso
prattutto sapere big ma vedo o crispi
noi non saluta finché schifo il team
subito su grazie enrico ciao 3 2 1 ciao
per ragazzi ci siamo appena resi conto
di una cosa è secondo me un sacco di
persone senza avevo già rese conto non
abbiamo messo il grembiule abbiamo fatto
una ricetta dimenticandoci dall'inizio
alla fine del grembiule c'è da dire che
l'abbiamo fatto nel rispetto di dio
nessuno mette a cristo in un angolo